you
all right it's been a while a crazy
house tournament three two time control
ah man this is just too much fun crazy
house let's see we get against Anonymous
Network
all right ah yeah I thought you might do
that okay
if Bishop to g5 there's Knight takes
Knight I'm pretty sure
hmm
I don't know so this is where it already
gets pretty crazy I start coming up with
silly ideas let's just take here and I'm
ready to drop a night somewhere I feel
like I want to do this let's give it a
go mm-hmm I don't have to take the Queen
um
and you got two nights I just feel like
this night on this square is going to be
too dangerous let's just recap sure yeah
I don't know oh ah look at the tricky
nights already man unbelievable
you're going to do a drop on one of
these two that's fancy yeah
so that's how it's working so you're
getting the material back and then and
then some
how to take here
I guess here so now I got two nights
though maybe I can do something fancy
yeah show you show use the boss hmm
meanwhile I have to stop Bishop check or
clean check here stuff I'm probably just
lost here
hm
I don't know what to do it's too tough
for me to calculate well the good news
that my opponent can hit me with
I just put my clean around for defense
I'm at some
trouble I don't have a good move
movement I don't know what to do I sorry
I just don't know what to do
oh yeah I mean you got that kind of
stuff I feel like I need to give up the
Queen and then let's try this
ah
connected really well ninety-two check
and then drop of Bishop here makes a lot
of sense defense de sense let's take
that guy out
and then I'll put a knight in a spot
where you can take some stuff the fence
I'm going to take this Knight this pod
Oh No
here
and don't hurt me
don't hurt me man please don't hurt me
hmm let's put this guy here
and I think it's a good idea not to take
the fiend cat out nights
so beat I've been living out for the
increment
there's Queen here Bishop takes your
stuff
you
get ready to run king
here we go this is where I die take out
you quick uncle uncle man uncle I'm in
trouble I have a feeling sort of in
trouble I'm dead
this is Farion so awesome I wish I was
on the winning end but I think I enjoyed
getting that beating I know
zero theory my apologies if you're if
you're a good crazy house player and
you're rolling your eyes
yeah I just I don't know any I like d4
d5 games feels like I could play longer
with that one efore e5 and I get pushed
around way too easily I'm still gonna
still going to go with this you see that
was a cool tactic you know it just was
irreparable weaknesses clean taking here
and then those tricky Knights are extra
tricky and crazy house should I've just
castled
I don't know
and so
they like a pin Ramon Korea Korea Korea
anyhow first-time opponent let's see if
you get Leon 81 is in first with a cool
a let's just keep the pin
I
I want to just careful you
let's see what stuff can I take a knight
upon and then I get those in my pocket
this guy probably not a good idea
all right maybe I could hunt down this
guy not quite my nights just going to
get stranded I shouldn't have done this
yeah this wasn't a good idea because
it's favorable that dropped your own
pieces somewhere on the kingside for two
reasons well kings are here means
there's that move okay I could take I
don't know it's just you you put a piece
here is it a good defender and it's one
less piece your opponent could
eventually drop you're your own king so
let's not get in the habit of just
backing up here is this my moment to
seize an initiative I'm going to try
got a look at these forceful moves and
crazy house for sure so what's the idea
I want to drop something on g3 I take
with the King just to stop a drop on g3
okay so now which piece would I want to
go to g3 with I thought a pawn
a bishop is interesting too I don't know
I'm not gonna be able to work out the
difference I'm going to go with the
bishop I would like a phone to end up
here so he's one step away from queening
so let's try with the bishop
I could take out a night drop a night
somewhere
if the rook moves I have a pawn drop
here
they got an item bishop maybe I just put
this guy here
yeah maybe it's supporting a piece on
this square one day
let's see I feel right around this point
I'm okay with sacking my queen for a
minor piece
like this position right here so we're
going to we're going to go for it
and I could do a night drop here let's
see how this turns out it's a fork still
got the fork so I got a night my pocket
and I could take a look at night of
Bishops so this should be good I think
I'm I'm their first I could take this
night this truck let's take a look I got
a night interrupt to work with maybe a
rook drop here is nice it's not check
but I still kind of like this I can also
scoop up the bishop
hmm so just take the bishop or drop
something here I'm going to go here this
is a really active rook
night check
three different night checks yeah oh you
know what they might do something fancy
like happened in the last game okay okay
I'm going to get hit with some nights
they got two nights okay what are they
setting up here okay so opposed I play
Queen here I think this is working let's
try this
rook takes and then I have a rook for
the back rank and I can put a rook on a
one
let's see they have to take because
otherwise I take here and then do a
night drop enough to for me even if they
interpose on this square so they must
still be considering this should not be
good be good for me and is this maybe
just a forced mate you feel like I
should have some force tonight so
definitely want to take with the pawn
and now a rook here so King f1 rook here
is leading to mate so now he must go to
the corner
and there he is so rook here or even
here oh this is going to be mate similar
idea because now I guess I get to take
and then drop the knight here for what's
close to a smothered mate not not
entirely but take here get a queen and
now no matter what night here next is
mate nice probably
I think instead of them dropping their
queen on g5 they probably had some some
good way to stir up some trouble against
me to break my Kings shelter just like
in the first game the night going into
h6 or f6
hmm
that was a cool game all right I got 231
in here zona Ches
it's got 12 all right this is the first
time playing his wife
efore
okay night on
edge huh what's open stuff up I like
that I could take him out right now
Bishop takes Knight and maybe even take
here next
I feel like this is just a very good
thing to do I mean look look at the
holes that are created now
what to do from here being eaten thank
you for the sub man appreciate that to
have a way to pounce it's just
by scooping that pond back up
it's very important to resist the
temptation to just go with the
stink xual you know with this variant
you have to look at the most forceful
stuff initiative initiative initiative
so that's a strong pawn
what about a knight right here
how about I insist on breaking down this
structure some
intersections square this guy right here
red hot
three pieces on it multiple
might be right around the corner
especially if we could get a clean
exchange in who knows how this is going
to play out hmm
okay they took I was looking at the chat
for a moment and they got a night in a
bishop but he was able to do anything
fancy I have a night I could turn in
there for a check I don't think I have
anything great okay then move suppose I
throw a punch right back
now two nights let's try that they got a
night yeah that move huh
good move Jake Goodwin
yeah I wish I was castled by now takes
here and then I mean now I just got I'm
gonna have to be down upon all right
they're going to get this guy back let's
see okay let's take here I got two
nights in a pond come on man do
something with it
drink castle they're ready to I don't
know there's ready to I don't know
okay I think I need a little shelter
maybe my Kings safer right where he's
out yeah we're going to live dangerous
maybe I go Queen side oh my goodness we
didn't hit with forks every which way
holy cow they're also playing pretty
quick
whatever now mad now mad you made me
angry now I'm going to start playing
fast okay yeah look at this defense man
you got a good barrier going on but
what's in your pocket
nothing look at this see how you like it
let's put that guy there in here fork
down I'm trying to burn my time is that
what's happening here
it's called queenside I got three nights
three nights they got one night okay
take my queen I'm on yours I should have
something good here
come on man
let's start with a bishop here
I got a lone defender I can't get at
that Don King I got three Knights but
what are they going to do I feel like I
need to put my queen here
just to be able to give check and give a
follow-up check seven point eight
seconds oh I could take here I could
take here and then a queen drop on this
square
they are focus on this guy who cares
about the look get rid of this clown
King takes bishop its mate should be
leading to mate somehow but I've seen
crazy things happening crazy house God
just take my bishop make it easy for me
you didn't do that all right let's try a
Pont now Bishop check keep that pond
around I have a queen check I realized
but Oh where's the mate man where's the
mate that mate close to mate and over
overload of fun crazy huh oh man wow wow
wow wow
ah geez thank you - Evi monk for the sub
with which crime hit that uh reload and
share button then you should be seeing
that alert pop up thinking it's regular
chess to Scandinavian is this really
good the Scandinavian for crazy house
I guess let's see alright you just ran
home you scaredy cat I'm playing against
tsunami of pawns I love that name
alrighty so I could drop a pond anywhere
I want but I'm going to keep that in my
pocket let's leave you keep you guessing
I thought we pointed something maybe one
day I could take care I need a pond all
right let's get castled I still got
something in my pocket let's point it
some more stuff maybe a night maybe a
pond maybe a clean I take one day
I got upon careful he's a sneaky guy any
one of these squares mm-hmm
all right now this is where I feel like
I could bring the pain bring the pain
take some stuff where's the initiative
seize it
we're already at the halfway point time
flies not quite 55 minute tournament
anyhow what we do here
hmm okay game on
Stuart taking advance
Japan's attack the pinch piece right
that's what they say that's what they
say
then we're going to back up we're going
to keep the pin make you work a little
harder nothing in the pocket no aren't
you living kind of dangerous doing that
hols all right we're going to take here
and made
we don't even go here
I'm not a pawn here
I like him as a good defender he's a
good guy now he's dead all right fine
I'm going after your king tsunami of
founds tsunami of pawns is ready to
throw a bunch of that's I think that's
tsunami of pawns plan all right where is
the Queen exchange and then a queen here
for mate can we manage that how do we
take care there's some pretty juicy
options to put upon where do you want to
go should I eeny meeny miny moe it I
don't know which one's best definitely
can't drop them on the rook um oh hey
yeah that's a fork no this bishops
they're defending now let's try that
that's a good support point right here
Bishop and pawn and is this where I go
entirely crazy and I need some more fuel
maybe they just try to hunt that pawn
down by giving me a piece to work with
they got a knight in the pond
pawn here I'll definitely cash out take
out a couple pawns okay so let's not be
too quick here I don't know what I want
to put on either these squares maybe
nothing
just take with the pawn and open this up
that feels like it's the best yeah I'm
going to keep these options open I don't
know if a bishop or upon
a lot of pieces converging right here
right here two pieces here three pieces
here I have a Bishop and pawn to work
with a bishop here it's check would be
nice okay
maybe I should start with this to check
I could take a night out and then a
knight right here let's do that I need a
knight to start bringing some pain here
there we go it's another check and I
could take up
let's check let's do it and what next
night on f5 is pretty deadly now uh he's
hitting a couple things also I mean my
queen is a pretty good defender against
any fancy stuff around my king I could
always sack her for a minor piece they
should be winning also here's here's the
winning idea put upon right here and say
these guys are super good yeah that move
I don't think that scares me
suppose I just take that rook let's take
the rook
I can take my queen with check but I'm
getting a night I have to say fur king
I'm covering the important squares rook
on f7 is he going to know he can't go
that way yeah I feel like I'm close to
mating here they have two bishops they
don't have a good blend of pieces they
could drop just two bishops right now
they'll have the two bishops in a queen
but what can they do that's great with
the two bishops our queen we've got a
lot of things to cover maybe a bishop
here I can move my knight in the drop
upon I have two pawns and not in a rook
so this seems like the right way to
start a rook here
I also just take that fish up okay let's
just start here my clock right there and
I have a night that I could drop with
check let's try that
and my clock
and here's the plan I just want to move
my night I want to I want a pawn or a
bishop here
threatening mate on our Bishop on g7
got some crazy nights I'm going to move
with the rook rook check and then pawn
drop for me
oh I didn't have much time okay
oh man got the W all right I got 824
minutes left
the zona chest took a hit one loss there
all righty
my first four varnas let's try a French
defense you could play the French
defense in crazy house that's okay right
okay you got some serious dark square
weaknesses
these squares are super sensitive I
don't know let's try my luck with this
opening
all right now what oh no I don't have
that move not quite all right
let's try this maybe I could win this
pond against a VAR nut
mm-hmm I'm tempted to do this let's try
it point out
let us see
take a bishop can maybe just go in
defensive mode
how about we develop
let's keep this king oh yeah this bishop
right around here to cover some squares
okay probably take with the bishop yeah
I don't want to give an opportunity for
some drop on b7
mmm-hmm look at just castle
moves I'm not sure where they're at you
know it's Castle putting some pressure
here clearly he's pinned
take stakes and then maybe I start
looking for captures here and how can I
get at the King may be clear this way
and get my LightSquared Bishop doing
something
mariel stick to
bishop in my pocket
let's see you
that's why going to come up with ready
just win a piece probably just take with
my queen
ah yeah hang out they have a night check
here I should be able to cover two
pounds in a bishop two pawns and two
bishops maybe the Nidal move scholars
mate let's see could take this night
with check if I need a night in the
complications the knight on f4 should be
pretty good I could maybe key in on the
f2 square okay
maybe this is where I no no no no no no
no I was going to say pawn here but
Bishop takes is already threatening a
queen drop here for me
okay I got this night check mmm
do I take the bishop I feel like I'm so
far away now no no too far away from
doing something like that maybe Queen
takes Knight
I think I have to still hold my ground I
might need to beef up my defense somehow
to have to talk to do that I don't think
so
yeah drop a couple pawns around my King
to defend need to get one of these
pieces in there let's see they got a
pawn in a knight to work with
45 seconds as well
18 minutes left in the tournament I
think I've ever won a crazy house
tournament
under 30 it's the bullet rating well
probably think I'm in okay well they're
gonna they could drop a night here yes
sir pretty much have to take that now I
got to work some magic really soon how
do I pull this off now we're going to go
in to prevent we're just going to go
defensive mode
I was ready to do something fancy maybe
I could just build up now okay they're
trying to drop stuff here
maybe not what's what's thread even okay
here's the plan
the plan is to put a bishop here that
move okay now I can start putting a dent
in their Kings side okay now I should
have something juicy
oh he's stepping up really aren't you
living kind of dangerous doing that pawn
push
now the Queen and the night put
something here though I have a night
drop here for check oh they're down at
time
I was pretty crazy there King stepping
up like that
I got 12 if I bruiser a game you lose
your increment
that would not be good this game just
finishes own a chest just one might be
getting paired up with zona Ches give me
white I don't know how much that would
help
let's see
give me a game one more game
two more games let's see me for it is
French be six and A six huh that's
pretty interesting pretty interesting
all right let's give him a shove I think
there
during this and then dropping in here
okay I just want to stop night f4
this is a really sensitive square let's
castle
all right they're playing
fast let's try this
okay
can I have take here
I'm going to give two to
is for the Queen I guess I guess that's
what they're going to go for you so take
the Queen first alright and now let's
just kind of stop the bishop from
observing squares around my king
okay that move so I play a little
defense here I want to put my clean out
too soon where can I put this pawn that
would hurt my opponent
all right I'm going to try to starve
trouble here giving up a pond just want
to open up some squares something here
or even here
it's still kind of like this idea
I could take
his phone they have a lot of stuff three
pounds a night inhibition interesting
position maybe I should try to get her
active I could sack this clean and then
have this one magically appear anywhere
maybe I could work with that
who night right here
oh wait a second what about a queen
right here right now we're not picking
up some material I think two unprotected
pieces I got nothing in my pocket but
maybe I'm able to scoop up something
soon okay what do I want the rook or the
night thing out on a night
also he's near my king so let's get rid
of a piece that's maybe won't close to
killing me
[Music]
let's see keep the Queen around night on
f6 kind of watch out for the night
checks
and on h3 that move Oh
how about this and then I'll be on the
rook they have to take on the rook
whit's check knight here hits a lot of
stuff let's try that
let's see
I have a bishop I should maybe key in on
this square right now do Knight takes
pawn
something here that's going to hurt can
I take some time out just to take care
I'm going to do that
they may try bishop
spawn
and that move okay
hmm
time alright they're going to do a pond
drop here let's let's take here
covering this oh they have a night drop
here I can't take I have to do this
yikes I might be getting made it somehow
night here I have a rook a bishop upon
bishops and pawns can't deliver check
let's try that
think I'm getting mated this covered
nice nice nice nice very good smothered
mate not the first time I've fallen for
that in the crazy house or regular chess
ah man nice nice nice nice
ah man that night on f4 combined with
their b7 Bishop killer alright let's try
the French this will probably be the
last game
that was a good finish yeah those
eh three square H six square
sets that stuff up sweeping into the f2f
7 squares alright I'll just take and
develop
maybe I drop my pawn on e4 the bishop
backs up let's see alright I guess I'll
be a little bit greedy why not
uh it's a close one here I wonder if
these two are paired up right now okay
so I got something
you
I cut a bishop they got two phones ah
okay they could just throw up on here I
don't know what I want to do is develop
a night
gee thank you for the 25 months in a row
man appreciate the support
all righty I don't think I have anything
good forward
I could go here now without fear of a
pawn on e5 released at the moment that's
all let's focus in on something how
about a bishop here now
let's see
I was thinking of Bishop c7 yeah okay
let's do this
I might have to go queenside takes a
while to get this Bishop out of the way
though I try this just keep the nice
thing you have to move the knight I
don't know let's try this Bishop here
and then I need to run away I could run
away this is a pretty nice fort
you
we'll take all right
I want to sneak away with my king if I
if I need to 1:34 my opponent five
minutes left in the tournament that move
alright let's cover some squares that
the night's hitting
and then some like licks here and I drop
there
we both have a night four minutes forty
seconds in the tournament that's what
they're going to go for let's try it
yeah let's try it
all right we're gonna go here
can i weather the storm you're you're
pulling me right out man
all right let's see you pull off the MA
here let's say it you got a couple ponds
you could drop but no good ones with
check I got three nights in a rook well
that move um what do I do
dangerous game here oh man
it's scary
rain check huh I think I need to throw
punches back
I can take here let's check take here
with check to continue some attack he's
doing beautiful things by the way he'll
jump over this pond and take here
great placement
35 seconds three nights okay I think I
need to take with the Queen cover some
squares this one take with the King
there's maybe this and then a rook drop
here no time to be calculating that I
got three nights come on man I got it
something good okay come on
there we go I got to clean
oh they just resigned you should never
resign who knows how that would have
played out I'm crazy house game sudden
end on page one that count for anything
I'm even going to get paired up I might
have been the last one can I hold on to
a front page page one confetti okay we
got one more
Lee chest Daft Punk all right
another French
I don't know let's go here let's be
aggressive might just want to take here
one day
the day
now you hear pond here pond there make
you to threat on here pond there for me
you can do a drop on one of these too
don't think this is maybe interesting
right point pieces around these squares
connect something with my night
main to threat boom on drop King here
pawn drop for me 45 seconds in the
tourney
oh they're giving me the mate Capri move
that phone back to tournament I'm still
in ten
four-way tie for seventh place there one
quick one in there that was that like a
nine mover not even
all right just a few seconds remaining
28 for anonymous network that was my
first round opponent 24 24 23 super
Walken was perfect awesome
I got then I got in sixth there how many
games is that eight games okay
44 players and all
games all fun as usual that crazy house